Those people opposite that spoke
will have you believe that somehow,
other than something normal and natural
in living in a society as well
as Katie says,
the dog eats dog,
the poorest go to the go to hell,
and the richest do well,
there isn't.
There isn't at all.
I believe in everybody there is an ounce of socialism.
In some people there's a pound.
In some pace people
there are many kilos of socialism.
Socialism is surely
about the kind of society you want to live in.
Do you want to live in a society
where there is no public provision
of any kind of service,
there is only private provision,
and the only thing to worship is money
and getting wealthy at the expense of others?
Or do you want to live in a society
where there is universal healthcare,
where there is a Protection
against a total destitution and poverty,
and every child gets to go to school?